[Applause]
welcome to dissecting the MU platform
security processor who are we this is Ho
bot he's a PhD candidate at the TU in
Berlin and his research focuses on AMD
encryption technology and I actually did
my master's thesis about the AMD
platform security processor with them
and what this exactly is I'm gonna tell
you in just a second so this talk is
going to present our firmware research
but we're not really firmware
researchers as is so we want you to get
to know our methods of reverse
engineering such a deeply embedded and
proprietary system such as the PSP so
this talk is suitable for everybody
who's interested in reverse engineering
everybody who might be curious what
processors inside processors do and
maybe also people who are into x86
firmware let's start off with the some
background if you've read the news
recently you might have recognized that
AMD's market share is growing massively
so it might it might be worth to look at
the security of AMD cpus more closely
than ever the AMD secure processor which
were going to call PSP in this talk is
an arm cortex a5 built into your AMD CPU
since 2013 it's as I said is CPU and
set.you CPU and it exists both on
desktop as well as server variants of
AMD processor so the current risin and
epic series unfortunately the PSP runs
undocumented and proprietary firmware it
doesn't have full access to the system
memory including your actual x86
processor and you might argue that it's
very similar to the internal management
engine some of you might have heard of
so what did we learn from others
regarding AMD subsystems there's the
system management you'd system
management unit responsible for power
management amongst others it was
detected by hood of malok already in
2014 at the 31 c3 and he managed to get
arbitrary code execution on this very
delicate piece of hardware the Intel
management engine was covered with two
talks at the at the Kaos Congress at
2017
there were several vulnerabilities over
the last years including remote code set
code execution there are therefore open
source projects that try to neuter the
abilities of the management engine so to
sum up our motivation for this research
and especially the focus of this talk we
wanted to reverse engineer that thing we
wanted to see if we can understand the
inner workings of the PSP although its
proprietary
there are cloud security or memory
encryption features by AMD which we're
not going to cover so much in this talk
but the PSP is a crucial component to
implement these and we're about to
publish a paper about these technologies
in the near future and of course system
security does the PSP make our system
more secure or does it make it less
secure first of all we need to talk
about the firmware and where the
firmware actually is because in the
beginning of this research we didn't
know where it is
what you see here is a Lenovo ThinkPad a
285 from the bottom you can coarsely
spot CPU under a heat sink you can spot
an SSD and what's but
two spot is an SPI flash this is a
non-volatile memory that that is
responsible for storing the bios or
today it's called UEFI so in a
traditional boot the CPU would first
grab coat and data from this SPI flash
and only then after having proper
drivers it can load such a complex thing
as an operating system from the SSD an
AMD boot looks a bit different as we as
we already knew before a research the
PSP was a crucial part of the boot
process in fact it boots before the x86
CPU comes up so we assume that might be
part of the of the yui fire or at least
it might be stored on the spi flash too
so the contents of the spi flash are
called UEFI image and this 16 megabyte
image actually is completely replaced
when you do what is still called often a
BIOS update the the format of this you
Aoife image is standardized so why don't
we just have a look inside using the
open-source tool you effectual we can
parse the UEFI image and what we see
here among other things is for example
that it's exactly the 60 megabyte in
size that's exactly the size of the spi
flash memory and we see some things
related to the efi to the boot process
of the x86 cpu what we also see is
something called a petting a non-empty
padding and this non-empty padding is
where it gets interesting using the
popular firmware analysis tool bin walk
or more specifically it's it's option to
recognize processor instructions of
different act
and using it on the BIOS image we see
that they're armed instructions inside
remember it's an x86 BIOS update so we
might be close to the PSP film and we
are looking for and we were really close
so the central data structure in what we
call the firmware file system of the PSP
is a directory which you can see here in
a hex editor mmm so a directory as we
found out starch starts with a magic
string in this case it's dollar PSP
there is a checksum that provides some
error detection but no nothing else
there's a number of elements that will
be listed in this directory and
something else we haven't find out about
one of those entries or each of those
entries consists of a type it's just an
integer size all in little-endian
and an address where it's located inside
the UEFI image and then there's one very
special type of directory entry which
actually doesn't point to for example
data or code but it pointed to another
directory which we call the secondary
directory this might be two to legacy
reasons maybe older PSPs could only
store 16 entries in the directories so
this was a way to actually have larger
directories than this but how did we how
did we get there how did we get to the
directory now we use bin walk to just
find some arm instructions somewhere
inside the UEFA image but to be able to
properly pass the firmware we had to
find the firmware entry table and this
fermenter table we found out about
through the core board project the core
board project is an open source bias
implementation which used to support
systems with early versions of the PSP 2
and the firmware entry table is there's
only one of those and one UEFI image it
begins with a specific
by its sequence and at least point us to
firmware blobs such as PSP directories
so now we end up with what we call
entries or what you could call the files
of the firmware file systems and that to
major and important types of entries you
found one type is a public key entry
this data structure holds information
about a cryptographic key that can be
used to verify signatures of other
components this is actually the only
data structure that is publicly
documented by AMD as it's part of one of
its memory encryption technologies and
apart from one special key the route
signing key all the keys can contain
signatures themselves too the second
important type is a header entry an
entry with the header and it contains
the header of 256 bytes with metadata
such as what key was I signed with and
these entries can have a trailing
signature and they can for example be
Zillah compressed compressed too so now
that I've shown you what we found out
about this proprietary simple file
system I want you to show I want to show
you peace patrol peace patrol is an open
source now open source tool we developed
to two powers PSP firmware from UEFA
images so what we have here can you read
this what we have here is a
UEFI update or bias update for the
Lenovo ThinkPad you saw earlier from the
bottom so using PSP jewel' we can get an
overview of all the directories and
entries that we passed from this so
using also some other older la boot
resources we found out
which integer type belongs to what kind
of strings so we found some things like
a PSP firmware bootloader something like
a system management off chip firmware or
similar things if you would like to
start exploring the firmware that runs
on your AMD processor you can for
example extract and uncompress all
entries of this specific firmware and
now what you will find is a directory
with all these entries as separate files
and for example Keys possible by open
ssl - if we want to have a short glimpse
inside one of those files we get for
example look up some strings in one of
those files let's say for example the
PSP booting trust lists whatever that is
and there we go this might be the
perfect starting point to start
reversing the PSP boot time trust let's
so peace patrol is available on github
you can get it and get a bias update of
your favorite machine and then check out
the firmware that's in site so now that
we got hold of the firmware itself of
course we wanted to find out if we could
execute our own code or if we could
manipulate existing code for that we had
to manipulate the UEFI image and this is
feasible in two manners
the first one is through software for
example through an operating system
sorry through a BIOS update utility
inside your running operating system
this will write the new you Aoife image
to a specific area memory trigger system
management interrupt and on the next
reboot it will write the new contents of
this UEFI image into your spi flash
memory then of course from the BIOS
configuration during boot up you can
oftentimes also program a new you if I
image but although this might be
suitable for a real world attack for our
experiments it's not very handy since as
soon as we would have a non-functioning
UEFI image the system wouldn't boot
anymore at all and we wouldn't be able
to get back to a functioning state so
that's why we did it through hardware
having access to the spi chip on the
mainboard and using an SPI programmer
now what you see here is again our
Lenovo ThinkPad and the background you
can you can see that we connect it to
the flash and what will you see in front
is an SPI programmer so the black thing
on the bottom is the programmer it's
like five hero Hardware in this case
it's combined with a 1.8 voltage across
if Terr since the flash on the lenovo
thinkpad
runs in an unusual voltage an SPI is a
really simple protocol it's also used
for SD cards and LCDs
you might have heard about a spi already
yesterday and drama Watson's talk about
the spy spy and it mainly consists of
four channels chip select that means is
the master the chipset speaking or the
slave the spi flash memory data out and
data in for communication in the
respective direction and the clock for
synchronization so with this we can
externally program the flesh and then we
can boot the system and see what happens
but the problem is this gives us only
binary output either the system boots or
doesn't boot but we wanted something
more sophisticated so we took a logic
analyzer a logic analyzer is an
electronic instrument that can record
the data flow on electronic lines logic
lines so we hook this onto the flash
then boot the system and recorded the
boot procedure and we want and and
through this we we wanted to see what
parts of the SPI flash are exactly
accessed at what time during the boot
process using the accompanying software
of this logic analyzer it's actually as
alia logic analyzer it's around 350
euros but there definitely cheaper ones
available you can see you can you can
really see what's happening so for
example this is a read command on the
data in line so that's that's a command
sent from the chipset to the spi flash
memory that the hex byte 3 is a read is
documented in the in the manual of the
spi chip and then what follows is an
address e 2 0 0 0 0 and then the flash
chip will gladly respond with data at
that position we're actually not so much
interested in the data that comes back
because as you remember this is what we
control we can program the SPI
flash memory as we want we're more
interested in the order of the read
commands especially so we wrote another
small tool it's called PSP trace it
takes one of those traces by the logic
analyzer on one hand and on the other
hand it takes in the the UEFI image and
it will parse the file system the
firmware file system in it and correlate
that information so what you end up with
is a really nice overview of the boot
process and it's first of all the proof
that the PSP comes up first
PSP code is loaded first and then only
later it follows the UEFI but we'll get
more into detail about this one soon so
from those experiments we gained some
important insights about this black box
the entries a cryptographer
cryptographically protected by signature
we didn't only find the signature we
found out if we would alter a byte in
the entry it wouldn't it wouldn't it
won't put anymore so one of those header
fields determines their according public
key compressed entries are actually
uncompressed first and only then they
are signature checked and there's the
header field that determines the the
exact size so as we also found out the
AMD root public key is does not have a
signature but when we would try to alter
this one and the system wouldn't boot
anymore so we assume there's maybe a
hash of the root key in read-only memory
what you can see here is just to give
you a glimpse of what this looked like
to us and in the beginning a header of
such an entry a body and a trailing
signature so with this I'm gonna hand
over to Hobart to tell you about what we
actually found out about the firmware
all right thanks so if you look again at
SBI trace of the PSP firmware you will
see something like this so in the first
four entries what you see here what
happens is the following so a component
usually an on-chip bootloader will read
the firmware entry table determine the
PSP directory lot the MD public key use
the MD public key to verify the
authenticity of the fw bootloader and
then execute it so you can see here
there's a rather large delay after that
happens so in that delay the PSP FW
bootloader which is loaded from flash is
executed so the PSP FW bootloader
initializes the the system and when it's
done that it will load additional
applications from the flash which you
see in subsequent accesses to the SBI
flash now so this this bootloader is the
first component which is loaded from
flash which contains instructions and
this huge delay gave us the idea that we
want to have close look at that specific
component right so we can extract that
component from an from an image using
the PSP tool and then just I don't again
first look at some strings let's see
what we find in this boot order so this
is an output of the strings contained in
a PSP bootloader from an aim D epic so
the server variant system so what you
see here actually there's some strings
which are interesting for us for example
it says piece BFW bootloader version
right so when you just have this
component at hand you might think about
what could it be but okay yeah that's
the string saying PSP FW bootloader
version so it's not too far-fetched to
say this is the PSP FW bootloader all
right so strings are always the first
thing you could imagine to check
maybe interesting but let's have a look
at the binary itself so as we know
already the first tax 100 bytes are just
the header so what comes after that so
we took the binary and put it into a
disassembly and what you would see at
the first instructions after the header
is something like this so if anyone here
has some experience with the ARM
architecture maybe someone already
recognizes what that is if not here's
the explanation so the ARM architecture
defines a table for entry points for
privileged code so any a synchronous
event such an interrupt system call a
page fault the CPU has to continue
execution at a specific address and that
specific address is defined in a fixed
table and this table the structure is
defined and when you look at the
highlighted part what you see here is
that at each offset you have a fixed
entry for the reset vector for undefined
instructions for supervisor call and so
on and each of those vectors is just a
single instruction so what happens is
that an operating system programs that
table in a way that okay the first
vector the reset vector jumped to my
initial initialization code and then for
the SVC vector this is just a jump to my
system call Handler and from there on I
will determine what system call happened
so when you combine those you see the
sixth entry is not used and the sixth
entry in our disassembly is an OP
instruction so it does nothing so this
is also a like educated guess from
outside this is the vectors table so
let's continue with that assumption if
that is the vector table we want to have
a look at the reset vector code because
that code initializes the system so well
this is the assumption so far and this
is are the first instructions which are
executed on the reset vector
so why are we going through this and the
first place so one thing we want to
learn to learn now is where in memory
this bootloader is executing because so
far we only know that it's loaded from
flash and that it's executed but we
don't know where it is loaded where in
memory ok so we look at the reset vector
the reset vector should initialize the
system and what we see there is there's
the reset vector we sit there a
configuration of register called V bar
so the V bar register on arm
architectures defines the location of
this table in memory and it's an
absolute address so this is a clear
indication that at address hex 100 the
PSP FW bootloader needs to have is it's
vector table and it's loaded at that
specific address so now we know the
physical load address of that component
and we know all the locations of the
different handlers for a system call for
page fault and so on alright now we
continue so this is the code snippet you
saw before with some additional lines
after that just a few instructions later
you will see that it enables paging so
the exact instruction here is not really
relevant just that for you to know this
last instruction on the slide here will
effectively enable paging so now we use
virtual memory where we need a page
table which converts virtual addresses
to physical addresses now where in
memory is that page table located again
an arm we have a specific register for
that
it's a TG b r0 and this register is
configured there so now we know the
physical location of this boot order
component and we know the physical
location of its page table right it's
page tables loaded at hex one four zero
zero zero it's also fixed physical
address so the next thing we wanted to
have a look at is how can we access this
page table we want to get more
information about the system so the page
table will define which virtual address
maps to which physical address which
with what attributes so
a page is writable or readable or
executable so we wanted to get that
information too so we know the address
of the page table but of course we just
statically analyze the binary we don't
have any access to the running memory so
what can we do about that emulation so
on a high level an emulator can emulate
the hardware environment of the device
so let's say we would be able to emulate
the PSP we could just stop execution at
an arbitrary point in time and read out
the memory at an arbitrary address so
that's how we could get the page table
so an emulator needs to emulate both the
CPU and the peripherals of the target
system so one of the most common
emulators and which is also open source
is chemo and chemo has support for arm
so this is good because the piece piece
also an arm CPU and chemo can for
example emulate a whole Raspberry Pi 2
but of course the chemo does not have
support for the PSP it's a proprietary
deeply embedded core which is not
whereas no information publicly
available so creamer can however emulate
the CPU part so just the core however we
don't have information of the memory
layout or any peripherals so for example
when you want to emulate an arm system
you probably want to emulate an
interrupt controller and there are very
common interrupt controllers such as the
geek V 4 or 5 or whatever none of those
is used in the PSP they use a custom
interrupt controller so we're kinda out
of luck there however there is avatar -
so avatar - is and framework that allows
you to implement device simulation in
python which is way simpler than having
to patch Kumu to support all of the PSP
functionality
a lot I can do a lot more but I will
just focus on the stuff we used from
that so what we have now is here's an
example of how such a simple device
simulation could look like so when you
have navitat to setup you can program a
peripheral with just defining two
functions in this example I define the
HW Reed and an HW right function the
right function does nothing just ignores
whatever is written to this peripheral
and the read function just returns an
arbitrary value so this is a stupid
device but it shows how simple it is in
Avatar to create a device simulation so
you can easily extend that example with
a more complex setup so this specific
device if you would map it to an address
of the emulation when you read from that
address it will always return the same
value now if you want to emulate the PSP
using Kimo and avatar it can be as
simple as I will show you now so when
our troll is it's python-based and uses
Kimo as a back-end you create an hour to
object and then you add memory
information to that object so you say
hey avatar I want to have a file loaded
into memory at this specific address so
for example this line the second line
here says load my bootloader binary
which are just extracted at address 0 so
then we have 100 bytes of the header and
at address hex 100 our reset vector
starts alright the bootloader uses some
stack so we'll give it just another
memory page of stack memory saying hey
at this address I give you some
additional memory if you look at the
disassembly of the bootloader
you will see that this is the exact page
that the boot order expects its stack to
be alright so now we have the binary we
have stack memory we add some
peripherals so the bootloader
expects some peripherals to be there you
don't need to really implement all of
the functionality but let's say the boot
order expects that there is an interrupt
controller which has a register saying
I'm version 5 so what you do is ok I add
a custom peripheral it does nothing
except for returning 5 at the correct
offset you don't care about the
functionality you just want emulation to
continue ok so I will add some
peripheral then I will just say ok I
initialize the Kumu target I set the
start address which is the hacks 100 I
set a specific CPU module I initialize
the whole thing I set a breakpoint to an
address where I want to stop the
emulation and then I call kimu continue
and this will start accumulation with
the memory layout I just defined in the
spicen set up and the weight will return
once the breakpoint is hit so this is a
very very simple way to emulate unknown
Hardware right I just looked up some
bits of where in the physical memory the
binary expects to be and then I just
start emulating and I don't even care
what any complex peripherals such as the
IQ controller I can just return the the
value that the code expects alright so
we have a demo for that and the demo is
also available on github so with the
demo you can emulate the PSP
firmware up to a certain part I need to
switch that's awesome
so let's soak the demography moss Worthy
showing you this demo
not to close off
all right so what you see here is I will
now execute the Python script which I
wrote to emulate parts of the PSP boot
or a firmware version
okay so you can see here it says virtual
timer and initialized device at some
address this is a implementation of a
timer device I implemented to make the
emulation run as far as I want it to be
it's a very very simple device again it
will just return an incrementing value
whatever something is read this is
sufficient to let the firmware emulate
up to a certain point now I set a
breakpoint and now it's stopped so what
can we do with that well I have now an
interactive ipython shell and my script
allows me to call disconnect gdb the
avatar framework controlled qmo using
gdb so now I detached it from gdb and I
will now attach my own gdb so this is
gdb
so now I've attached the gdb to the
emulation running inside Kimo so this is
kind of nice I can inspect some of the
instructions so this is the instructions
which are currently emulated I stopped
at the very first line and coming back
to our original plan right we wanted to
dump the page tables if you can remember
so the Patriots are at the fixed address
the breakpoint I hit here is past the
function that will generate the page
tables so I just have a peek at the
address where I expect the page tables
to be and there they are
I doesn't look too fancy so what you see
here is the dump of the page tables of
the PSP so of course this does not say
too much right I don't know how many of
many of you can read page tables by just
looking at that I hope no one we have
where is it of course we have a script
for that yeah there it is
so what I did now I dumped the memory
containing the page tables and this is a
simple Python script that parses the
page tables this is a lot of information
so I will just highlight what's
interesting here the way to read it is
it starts with a virtual address which
maps to a specific physical address and
you can see it's just one-to-one
mappings not too interesting now it gets
interesting
exactly here so if you lip look at that
those four lines in the middle you can
see the AP bits right so right there AP
bits are the access permission bits so
these bits determine who has access to
those page tables and you can see
everything which is below hex one five
zero zero has a p1 everything after has
a p1 one now if you look up the eye menu
you will see that it means everything
after hex one five zero zero is users
coat everything above is the operating
system code so now we have another piece
of information about how the PSP loads
its application and where I've been know
now exactly the user space applications
or rather their address space starts as
a fixed address and of course these page
tables could change over time right I
stopped at a specific breakpoint kind of
early on so maybe they change
well they don't so this is the page
table layout of the PSP throughout the
whole usage of that processor alright ok
coming back to the slides
okay
so yeah one thing you can find the
scripts for the emulation on github I
will show the links later on so you can
actually run your own emulation of the
ps3 firmware if you want okay some
insights what we gained here so this is
the memory layout of the PSP the
bootloader is loaded at offset zero it
has a header of 100 hex 100 bytes and it
starts execution at exactly hex 100 it
is privileged code it handled syscalls
interrupts at loads applications then we
have the page table at this specific
address and everything below that up to
a certain point is application code so
mmm interesting here is that at one
point in time there was only one
application so the way this works is the
boot order has a fixed order of
applications which are loaded once an
application is running and finish this
the next is loaded and so on so there's
no much if reading at all so very simple
setup mmm so the user spit userspace
applications there are many of them so
for example if you're familiar with the
secure encrypted virtualization
technology this technology uses the
firmware and this firmware is a user
space application on the PSP also we
have applications which trained dear em
for example so in modern x86 system if
you have ddr4 memory it has to be
trained so you have to measure the
timings of the specific drm chips which
are using and the application that does
that is a user space application on the
PSP um we had to look at some of the sis
codes which are handled by the
bootloader which is actually more an
operating system than just the
bootloader I would say um so we have
cache maintenance so scrolls
we have syscalls which map an arbitrary
x86 memory address into its own address
space
we have sis codes which provide the
applications access to a crypto
accelerator if they want to do some
cryptographic operations we have random
number and we have functions to read
additional components from flash so also
user space application can load
additional components from flash so some
words to the security of the whole thing
a salar is a technique which randomizes
the virtual memory layout of
applications in order to make it harder
to mount a buffer overflow for example
and stack Canaries are like random
values which are inserted the epilogue
and prologue of a function to be able to
detect the buffer overflow yeah of
course we don't have any of those it's
very simple no relation at all and also
what is interesting usually when you
have an operating system in the user
space application every syscall which
gets a pointer the operating system has
to be very careful about sanitizing
these pointers so a new specification
could provide an pointer to the
operating itself operating system itself
which then uses that pointer to write
value to write so you usually want to
check whether your user space
application that called assist crawl
provide you with the right pointer so
they don't do that here ok you could
argue this is all kind of AMD code and
it's signed and trusted and whatnot the
thing is the applications are not only
provided by AMD and aim signed with the
AMD key they're also provided for
example by UEFI vendors or mother bought
vendors and signed with their key so I
would say it's rather disappointing that
there is no security check in the
syscalls
as there are probably vendors that aims
you should not trust too much all right
coming to our conclusion so takeaways
for you I hope
we gave some insights to you how to
approach such a problem at what you can
do so the emulation part is something
you hopefully can also do on your own
now PSP to land PSP Trace is available
for everyone so if we want to look at
your BIOS images from these systems you
can do that now quite easily and also
this SPI tracing using PSP tree is a
very very helpful analysis method
because it gives you the exact idea of
which component is loaded when and if
you're further interested in the secure
encrypted virtualization technology and
how the firmware or home security issues
in the firmware could affect it there's
a paper pending which is going to be
published at CCS 19 ok some thanks there
is peter sugar who provided us with an
flasher for spi flash that allows us to
easily and fast flash the flash which is
very helpful Mario's Muench who
developed avatar 2 and the secti
department and as all apps berlin for
providing us with hardware that we can
have a look at there are the links
thanks
all right make a pause for them great
job great job and thank you for this
very insightful talk yeah all right so
we have some short time left for some
Q&A who's interested in in asking some
questions okay so let me just come over
to you so we get your question on the
recording yeah thanks for the talk so
it's the whole image signed as well I
would I end up with a valid UEFI image
of us just remove some applications
let's say those who've been the ones I
do not trust and hopefully aren't
required to boot the system them so in
general no it's not the it depends the
the answer is it depends some BIOS
vendors have an image over the whole
UEFI image but this is actually only
checked if you use for example their
BIOS update utility so if you use an SPI
programmer this won't stop you from
actually removing for example one of
those entries are also replaying entries
for example from another UEFI image that
are assigned with the same key my
understanding is the initial reads of
the flash the spy flash occur they have
they're done by some kind of boot rom
were you able to access the boot rom no
so we didn't find any code regarding
this inside the flash image but of
course if it's in ROM it doesn't have to
be in the in the flash we didn't I will
poke too so maybe I can tell it like
this so we actually have some ways to
access the PSP's memory directly right
now and we poked a bit in its memory
around and we didn't find any code that
could be something like an on-chip boot
ROM but we suspect it has to be there
but some part has to access the flash
and load the second stage from the flash
and verified its its integrity all right
do we have any more questions yes
over there one second
hello things for the talk how did you
manage to find out the meaning of those
registers that are early on set like
page table address this is defined in
the arm reference so did we notice an
ARM Cortex CPU and the arm v7 manual
specifically says which register is
doing what so this isn't known and
there's a very nice Ida plugin that
actually makes comments on all those
weird coprocessor instructions and tells
you exactly what they do it's very handy
so what they're some form of obligation
on the client or on on the boot server
or under ops no it's all playing our
code to be disassembled yes good to hear
hey so you say you can pick and replace
whatever user space programs other
people have written for different
motherboards different manufacturers
have you started collecting all these
from all the different ports have been
made to kind of analyze and see if
there's any interesting stuff there or
do you have such an online collection
somewhere we have a small collection of
images locally and we try to distinguish
the vendors whether there are some
differences or not we don't have an
online version of that the thing is if
you look at epic you will see mostly the
same now no differences between the
different vendors of motherboards Rison
I'm not too sure I can tell you that in
general the Rison is much larger
firmware with a lot more components than
for epic but we have not looked into
Rison that much actually all right any
more questions from the audience
ok looks good so thank you again thank
you Robert thank you Christian
epic applause again
[Applause]